[Music]
in part two of an exclusive cbs news
investigation we're taking a look into
why doctors are often not disciplined
for causing their patients harm state
medical boards which are responsible for
licensing and disciplining the doctors
have just one goal above all else
to keep the patients safe but our
year-long investigation reveal that
is not always happening our
investigative team talked to more than
100 malpractice attorneys in all 50
states
and they heard the exact same thing
after doctors harmed their patients
medical boards often look the other way
this morning jim axelrod shows us why
the public often has little idea
who these doctors really are she was
paralyzed and had what they call drop
foot which is basically where your left
foot just hangs down
it does nothing when jeremy payne's
mother regina bruce had spinal surgery
in 2008
her left leg was left paralyzed she
settled a medical malpractice suit with
the surgeon
dr steven sfabeck who has a long history
of problems
in indiana it's pretty bad that
people can get away with what they have
in these situations
people doctors doctors are licensed and
disciplined
by state medical boards panels made up
almost entirely of fellow physicians
what folks have to realize is that the
medical board
is not a substantial barrier to them
being injured by a physician
dr john hall spent 25 years practicing
pediatric anesthesia and critical care
later in his career he went to work as
the executive director of the
mississippi medical board
most medical boards are constituted of
physicians who are political appointees
and that is an inherent conflict of
interest
the people who are policing the doctors
have an interest in protecting the
doctors
absolutely but after dr hall pushed the
mississippi medical board to be more
aggressive in disciplining doctors
he found himself out of a job i believed
in the mission of the medical board
and i thought this is a place where i
can do this and do some good
you were pushing too hard absolutely
do members of the general public
understand
everything they could understand about
the doctors who were treating them oh
absolutely not
robert oscar spent 15 years at the
department of health and human services
in washington
where he worked with the national
practitioner data bank
a federal database used by hospitals to
keep track of bad outcomes by doctors
osha says there's a problem the national
data bank doesn't share doctors names
with the public
if doctors names were listed in the data
bank would it save lives
sure because there are physicians who
have very bad records who are still
practicing osha scoured the data bank
and turned up an alarming fact
less than two percent of doctors are
responsible for more than half
of all malpractice settlements it's a
very small proportion of physicians that
have caused the bulk of the problem
and even worse only one in seven have
had any action
taken against them by any state meaning
most of the bad doctors are still
practicing
right you know kind of whenever you buy
a car it has a carfax
you know it's almost like a doctor
should have a doctor fax
jeremy payne's mother was operated on by
dr steven sfabeck
google him and you won't find anything
about his list of malpractice
settlements in indiana
or the three sanctions dr svabeck
received more recently from the florida
medical board
really i don't have any comments to make
about any questions no the indiana board
was made aware of dr svabeck's problems
in florida
so we traveled to indianapolis for the
hearing if you had a chance to speak to
the board what would you say
how many more lives are you going to
allow him to ruin
the first paper when dr svabeck's case
came up we were surprised to see that
not only was dr svabek not present
he didn't even have an attorney there to
represent him
the board fined dr sva back a thousand
dollars and moved on
we asked for an interview with board
president dr john strobel
they didn't make him available so when
the board took a break
we tried to get some answers i'm jim
axelrod with cbs news
okay i'd like to ask you a couple of
questions of course i can't why can't
you uh we have a
hey mike yeah well you're the chairman
of the board and i would like to ask you
some questions about dr svabeck's case
mike can you direct him to the right
person you're the right person sir
you're in charge
are you telling me the buck doesn't stop
with you
now the mission of the indiana medical
licensing board is to protect the public
is the sanction just given to dr svavek
consistent with that
dr strobel didn't respond to a single
question we asked
he had nowhere to go including the
escalator jim i'm going to get nervous
next time i see you approaching with the
tv
crew but after all this reporting what
have you heard about why the medical
board seems so reluctant to pull the
doctor's licenses
when they know they're not doing a good
job
right right so that's the question gail
that we kept asking
throughout our reporting why with a
system in which two percent of the
doctors account for 50
percent of the malpractice awards and
settlements
why isn't there more vigilance on the
part of everyone in the system insurance
companies medical boards doctors
to target the bad actors and over and
over the experts
told us the same thing when you have
doctors policing doctors there's a
certain amount of reluctance built into
that system
to suspend or revoke licenses and the
degree
to which there are positions reserved
for non-doctors
on state medical boards is the degree to
which you will have
some independence and autonomy on that
board
right jim i have to say we were all
talking about your piece here at the
table we were really looking forward to
it and it certainly delivered
tony you touched on it yesterday as a
patient do we just have to rely on the
doctors to tell us the truth
is that how it goes well it's like it's
like what the what the man said in the
piece he said there should be a car
a carfax a carfax for for doctors if
hospitals can track it then people
should be able to track it and if
somebody in congress is watching this is
definitely something to take up in
legislation that information should be
public
yeah absolutely jim i forgot to say
thank you to you so thank you
thank you jim axelrod but thank you what
do patients do
if i'm so if we're supposed to have a
surgery just rely on the doctors to tell
us the truth
i think you're getting at something very
important here that national
practitioners data bank
let's open that up so that you can check
it out yes
thank you very much jim alex